[Musique]
comment allez vous ça va je suis heureux
c'est bien les gars j'ai un torticolis
quand je regarde j'ai très mal c'est
arrivé qu'à au lit parce que c'est un
torticolis une hotte pour cette blague
tout de suite tu as reçu par la poste ou
amazon on tente e-coli la note vient de
baisser de la proposition choisi une
nouvelle
aujourd'hui on va jouer à use your world
users il n'y avait joué il ya un an et
demi
oui les règles très simples je crois
qu'ils avaient plein de mécanique
différentes mais en gros à chaque fois
il ya une situation soit une image ou
une vidéo et on doit compléter cette
situation chacun notre tour via le
téléphone et puis ensuite on voit les
réponses que les hôtes ont mis chacun
alors oui le jeu était en anglais ils
ont sorti une mise à jour en france moi
je suis un puriste immersion allait
révolutionner le cinéma
fogarty pour solde de tighten up en
france à quoi souhaiter très bon camp et
vous quelle est la portée des autres
[Musique]
com
c'est tout alors je suis au niveau moi
aussi moi je suis au niveau
voici ce que vous avez écrit cairote
un peu genk
[Musique]
c
dans ce cas
[Musique]
com
vous allez encore non mais c'est le jeu
qui fait aussi des propositions a alors
avant de commencer petite particularité
l'une des réponses en fait ce sera celle
du jeu si vous votez pour la réponse du
jeu c'est moins 250 points et
médiatement et deuxième truc à savoir
c'est que cette réponse vous pouvez
l'utiliser vous même si jamais vous
n'avez pas d'inspirer à une option qui
s'appelle agricole sur vos téléphones
matt sorum et vomit pas super le
heureusement qu'il avait sûrement voyons
le résultat des votes
dommage c'était une enfin une chance de
faire l'actualité
c'est parti pour et toi exploit bah je
viens d'être démobilisé
c'est pas fou là encore c'est le jeu au
sol et laref maintenant voter pour votre
réponse préféré est assez stressante pas
savoir qui a fait quoi
c'était une obsession la loi il ya un
jeu est plus drôle c'est chaud se
chauffe l'appli vintage dernier cri
c'est parti pour ben comme ati la vache
qui rit souvent des moins bien quoi elle
s'appelait bien parano voyons le
résultat des votes
c'est parti pour ce top de taito voici
ce que vous avez écrit
[Musique]
ah mais régaler bling comme ati je vois
elle seule que j'adore les musiques de
jeux j'ai besoin d'être un parc
d'attractions hockey au nom si un
troisième mort alors c'était le premier
degré de la vidéo mais khalid et si
jamais vous foutez moi c'est tout
deuxième dans les 100 euros
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti pour ce temps les gars
j'adore ce jeu est vraiment épatant que
j'avais oublié ce que tu viennes mois
l'aja vos collégues assez je suis le mec
le moins drôle de france au nom vous
allez croire c'est l'arrêt du jeu long
et pourtant que la libye est ce que tu
es un lien est pourtant déjà à l'épée
est ce que tu alignes moi c'est toi café
samax c'est un camion sera soumise hier
des résultats des votes au qui moi je
voudrais c'est gentil ces briques
ouais c'est une brute avec des trucs
dessus dans les mairies qui arrivent
dans des trous j'ai pendant suis ni
besoin d'amis
[Musique]
il ya un truc de steve o c vrai nom
mathieu gallet rebondi dessus
voyons le résultat des votes
je vous ai juste et la mienne celle là
[Musique]
donc moi l'étoile coup de main mika
donnera un coup de main aux croyants vos
rêves rejeté possible après pour faire
céder pour moi on a tous une force
intérieure sur fond d'appels de karmann
moi je l'appelle
[Musique]
[Rires]
oui tout est 3ème
[Musique]
ça ne va pas on va voir un extrait de
film sous titré il va falloir contre
moubarak
je décide pas à avoir honte j'ai mal
jugé
juju fausses annonces âgées labo amis
juges arbitres et maintenant je change
les choses non voici ce que vous avez
écrit ailleurs c'est my edge et regarde
que pour la gagner celle-là je viens de
l'absolu de support informatique
je ne savais pas que tu pouvais pas
arrêter pour leur disent simplement en
est la musique ça fait un peu sous la
tente
j'ai dit à 30% désolé ça ne la suit pas
capté sa fin pour dire voilà ce que vous
avez proposé confie
[Rires]
pourtant c'était ma première évidemment
voyons le résultat des votes qui tint
bon bah c'est moi mais j'ai chaud mais
là mais j'ai pas ne sais pas si je suis
pas voter pour le mien c'est compliqué
c'est bon
toi ô ô bon ses larbins de cette vidéo
les gars je me suis dit c'est bon j'ai
rigolé très fort thür avait en tout cas
de lui aussi encore et c'est ouf comme
ce jeu on est à la pression c'est drôle
parce que t'as pas envie de décevoir tes
potes invités qui rigole fort parce que
jugés ouais y'a un truc moi j'ai fait de
la musique achetée il ya with à la
logique d'un sic un moment on dirait un
truc suis passé et capteurs truc de fête
foraine quand céline pas d'attractions
la wii pas vraiment les messages et
j'avais j'en ai parlé autour du goûter
n'hésitez pas à suivre les instagram de
ces gens et les chaînes youtube tout en
descriptions même si vous les connaissez
maintenant et je vous recommande ce jeu
c'est pas une op mais franchement il me
rend ma wen je vous recommande d'y jouer
avec vos pauses c'est marrant pour
savoir quel point tu es drôle et quel
point faut changer au joli trio à
bientôt
merci d'avoir regardé si où les gens
[Musique]